engaging with China France's president
and the head of the European commission
both in Beijing the hoping Xi Jinping
can help end the war in Ukraine but with
China accused of siding with Russia what
can it offer this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program I'm Nick
Clark so EU leaders are in China for a
high stakes meeting with President Xi
Jinping French president Emmanuel macron
says he's counting on China to bring
Russia to its senses and in the war in
Ukraine macron is joined by European
commission president Ursula vondeline
she says China's position on the wall
will determine its future relations with
the block so can Europe change beijing's
mind on the war in Ukraine and how is
trade shaping relations between the two
sides plenty to discuss up ahead but
first Robert McBride sets it up for us
French president Emmanuel macron being
given the honor of a state visit welcome
by his Chinese counterpart Xi Jinping
one of Europe's most influential leaders
coming to ask China to exert its
influence on Russia to bring an end to
Europe's worst conflict since World War
II is
I know that I can count on you to bring
Russia to reason and everyone to the
negotiating table
this was Xi Jinping visiting Russian
President Vladimir Putin last month
since moscow's Invasion more than a year
ago Beijing has stayed neutral and
proposed a road map for a ceasefire and
peace talks most western leaders
including macron have criticized the
plan but the French president has been
one of the more conciliatory voices
among NATO heads of state
two weeks before Russia's Invasion he
met President Vladimir Putin in the
Kremlin and has spoken to him several
times by phone over the past year many
are now watching to see if macron and
she together can provide a breakthrough
where others have failed
China insists on a peaceful resolution
and is willing to work with France to
maintain the rationality of the
International Community and avoid
actions that could further escalate the
crisis or let things get out of control
in a show of European Unity macro is
accompanied by European commission
president Ursula Von delayan who has
taken a much tougher line on China's
failure to condemn the Russian invasion
the Europeans are looking at the very
least to dissuade China from supplying
Russia With Arms we also count
on China not to provide any military
equipment directly or indirectly to
Russia because we all know arming the
aggressor would be against international
law and it would significantly harm our
relationship
the signing of lucrative trade deals on
this trip is seen as beijing's attempt
to maintain good European relations even
as ties with the U.S sour I hope China
will tell president macron on the one
hand and then tell Madame avondalea on
the other hand that it is absolutely
important to have a European perspective
which may or may not be exactly
identical to that of the United States
Chinese and European leaders hoping
traditionally strong trade links can
lead to a diplomatic breakthrough Rob
McBride Al Jazeera
foreign
who's a senior research fellow at the
global policy Institute which is an
independent think tank in Washington DC
in the U.S Colleen Cottle the deputy
director of the global China Hub at the
Atlantic Council and in Beijing in China
Andy mock who's a senior research fellow
at the center for China and
globalization welcome to all of our
guests says Jack if I could start with
you in France why why does dual pronged
approach do you think president macron
and Wonderland on this combined visit
is to show that France is part of Europe
and the macron knows that China prefers
to have bilateral relationship relations
with other countries like was the case
when uh Olaf Schultz went to Beijing and
before uh with China and mercor very
often dual meeting but Macau is insisted
on showing that France yes is a little
different country but is part of the
European Union and that when dealing
with China with 1.5 billion people it's
better to deal from a basis of
representing the European Union with 450
million people that a country like
France with 70 billion people so
therefore he insisted on bringing us 11
the alliance as five years ago when Xi
Jinping made a state visit to France he
invited miracle and the president of the
European commission to take part in the
discussions so it's very important for
Macon who especially is very insistent
on highlighting the fact that Europe as
a strategic autonomy as
person as interests and values which are
not necessary those of its allies such
as America to show Europe as a political
identity and France has always always
promoted the idea of a political
European Union
I will come to the U.S and insect with
Colleen but first Andy mock in Beijing
for for the president Xi Jinping the
Optics pretty good aren't they two of
the most powerful people in Europe
coming to him he'll like that Wendy
yeah
well I think certainly uh China
recognizes in presidency recognizes that
China has important contributions to
make on the global stage whether that's
in Europe uh whether that's in the
Middle East uh with the recent
reproachment between Iran and Saudi
Arabia and other parts of the world as
well so certainly I think it's no
surprise uh that we're seeing these
visits and more to come I believe the
Pedro Sanchez from Spain will be
visiting China uh shortly as well
and Colleen Europe's kind of stuck in
the middle between China and the United
States to what degree is the U.S wanting
this conversation between Europe and
China
I think the United States would like to
see
um action from China on on Ukraine that
would bring us closer to a resolution
um that you know if there is an ability
for you leaders to help gain traction
urge China on this I think there is
skepticism here and probably in parts of
Europe on whether that's actually
possible or whether this visit just
gives she um The Diplomatic win of
looking like he's playing this Grand
Statesman hosting
um European leaders but not really put
on the spot to make any movement towards
towards the resolution
um so I think there's there's hope but I
think there's also at the same time sort
of skepticism and awareness that this
may actually be counterproductive and
just feeding she's sort of in view of
China as being the the center of the
world stage and all things must run
through him and you know the rest of the
world must kind of accommodate China's
views and positions
indeed how closely do you think Colleen
EU policy aligns to the U.S policy on
China
well I think the the speech that
funderline gave um last Thursday really
you know whether that represents the
entire EU or not I think is a an open
question but a lot of those the analysis
that's contained in it that China is
moving kind of a turning a page on
reform is moving you know to I see more
of a security focused State rather than
a trade in Economic Development
um it's kind of the driver of its
policies I think a lot of what she said
does align with what the the US is is
thinking and how the the US world view
of China kind of generally is I mean the
US view is not of course monolithic but
there is this
um I think growing impetus to see China
you know as a increasingly as a
competitor um in the global stage and I
think vendor Lions comments do say that
maybe not quite as pointedly as some of
the remarks coming out of the United
States uh and I think some of the
solutions she's proposing are also in
line with some of the economic solutions
that that we are looking at in the
United States in terms of making sure
that you're protecting
um interests in your countries against
Chinese coercion she referenced the need
to potentially look at outbound
investment screening mechanisms for key
technologies that could uh if you know
fallen into the wrong hands be used to a
Chinese military capabilities so a lot
of these these statements and the
policies are in line I think the
question is whether the E will be United
enough to sort of see them all through
together or if there is kind of
divergences in the EU commission
policies versus National policies that
the Chinese can exploit
how did that speech go down in Beijing
Andy because it's a pretty from
Wonderland it was a pretty uh sharp and
pointed uh Speech wasn't it fairly
critical of China
well I think that the view uh from uh
China would be that uh clearly Europe is
staking out a separate position the key
phrase here I believe that was used is
uh de-risking not decoupling
and I think that shows uh the European
recognition uh that it cannot blindly uh
follow the U.S going off a cliff uh as
it were
um with this the other point I want to
make too is this uh I think it's a false
choice or it's presented as a false
choice between a more security oriented
State uh versus one that is committed to
trade and investment
uh in fact I think uh China's pursuing
both
uh it recognizes that uh it's facing an
incredibly complex uh geopolitical
environment that really hasn't been seen
in a very long time uh and requires a
strengthening of uh government
structures alignment of the party uh the
government and the people but at the
same time uh trade and investment
greater integration uh with the parts of
the world that are willing to work with
China including Europe
uh is vitally important and that these
mutually reinforce each other and are
not uh distinct and separate choices uh
and either or black and white binary uh
approach but in fact it's both Jacques
as you had mentioned in Wonderland and
macron going hand in hand as it were but
how much Unity is there in Europe about
the their approach to uh to China and
indeed the U.S approach to China or is
there Divergence
there is Divergence uh between Europe
and the US on the attitude to China
Europe doesn't want a confrontational
attitude to China France is unwanted
Germany doesn't want it most European
countries do not want it but they
realize that it has about time to also
rebalance our trade with uh with China
to reduce risk for a while Europe was
seen a bit as the global village idiot
to accepting all kinds of investment in
his uh country all kinds of imports and
not asking for reciprocity from China
Festival on the issue of public markets
and therefore
that's why there is a threat in in June
there's going to be discussions on
global investment act in order to see
how Europe can defend itself in This
Global world where it has suffered a lot
in terms of imports France and Europe
import far more than the export to China
so now it's a time but at the same time
get the issue of trade and economies is
very important but here Mac also wanted
to put uh forward the idea that China is
not only a competitor but is also a
partner it's a partner especially is the
fight against global warming and the
fight to preserve biodiversity and today
in press conference there was quite a
lot of emphasis on this issue the fact
that the many contracts which have been
signed between France and China today
involve companies which are actually uh
very involved in water and environment
issues which can help China with their
attitude so there's the attitude a
competitor but we have to maybe redraw
the rules a little bit but at the same
time a partner and that's why they think
there is something to be done especially
they realize that the Europeans were a
bit miffed by the fact that when you
when Americans invest instigated the
inflation rejection act that it only
benefited European companies so uh
Europe is aware of the fact that America
flies for its interest first Europe has
to defend its interests first and at the
same time Europe knows that we don't
know who's going to be in power in 2024
in uh us so it's very important for for
Europe to assert itself on the
industrial scene
it will come come to trade more in a
second in a moment or two but Andy Mark
said macron he wants China to Reign
Russia for Russia for China to Reign
Russia in on Ukraine
um how ready is China to work with
France to push hard to obtain a
negotiation to end the war do you think
well I think China's position on the
Ukraine conflict has been clear and
consistent uh and that a peaceful
settlement uh should be reached and
these types of uh contradictions uh
should be settled through dialogue and
and not through violence but we also
have to recognize that China is actually
not a party to this conflict
um Russia is
Ukraine is
countries actually supplying military
gear uh and intelligence to the parties
to the conflict are the ones with the
real power to end this uh conflict so of
course China France uh other countries
uh can urge uh the parties to the
conflict uh to reach a peaceful
settlement but it's only the parties the
two or the three parties uh that are
directly engaged in this conflict that
can actually bring it to an end Colleen
what's your view on that I would
disagree I think China may not be
providing and we don't know there's
there's a lot of accusations
um and there's maybe proof behind closed
doors in terms of China's provisional
lethal aid but it is providing you know
is is buying large amounts of energy
from the Russians so it is indirectly
keeping the war machine running in
Russia by those purchases yes maybe if
China wasn't purchasing some of that it
would be purchased elsewhere
um but at any rate China is making those
purchases and so there it does have some
influence over Russia
um to you know to be trying to bring the
war to conclusion so I think it is
indirectly I think it is fair to say it
is a it is a part of the couldn't be
part of the solution in this part of the
the war effort
um but I I agree that the Chinese want
to stay really you know kept move it
move it into a dialogue they certainly
have been pushing for that
um how however realistic their proposal
plan is I think you know it's a it's an
echoing of common mantras that the
Chinese
um you know it's Echoes what's in the
the some of the language and the Global
Security initiative that's China's kind
of solution to things is
non-interference respect expert
territorial Integrity
which is a kind of a confusing one to
treat in the context of the Ukraine war
um but really you know for the for the
Chinese I think in some ways they would
like this to just go away they want they
don't want to see Russia
um fall because that that that 4 000
kilometer border could still instability
into into
um to spillover into China from from
Russia they certainly don't want to see
it the the conflict move in such a way
that it would put Putin's
um you know standing within the country
at risk and then trickle over into China
but I think they also don't like the
pressure they're getting from the West
about stepping into the conflict more
and I think that was part of the
starting stepping into the conflict in
terms of helping bring to part of the
solution I think that was part of the
motivation for this 12-point plan and so
they do see them they are caught in the
middle and I think recognize this this
12-point plan was was trying to get them
out of that metal get them out of the
hot seat a little bit and I think you
know the Europeans are again trying to
raise this raise the pressure up and
whether that's gonna trigger any
different policy I think I'm a little
skeptical so Europe is trying to raise
the pressure Jack what leverage if any
does the EU have on China for them to
lean on Russia but the The Leverage that
uh EU has on the China is that uh first
the EU is the main importer of Chinese
goods and is necessary for the French
for the Chinese economy at the moment
which is not growing at its usual Pace
three percent and five percent related
for last year and five percent this year
which is not much and uh the China is
victim of American sanctions so the best
customer
remaining for China is Europe so it's
important and also Europe is seen as in
the vision of the word order that Xi
Jinping as he sees it it says the birth
of a multiple world no longer a world uh
ruled about America in a way with
America as the hyper power as before the
New World Order is being established now
and he appreciates the fact that Europe
especially not everyone in Europe but at
least macron wants Europe to be an
independent poll in a multiple world and
which could help and to go back to the
issue of uh Russia yes uh China as and
Ukraine China has no uh
no beef really in that issue actually
the Ukraine war has been very good for
China it gets cheap gas and now for the
first time in the Chinese Russian
relationship uh China as clearly the
upper hand but let's not forget today
there was some kind of breakthrough
showing that uh China wants to involve
itself in a role as a peacemaker maybe
not a peacemaker but at least the force
of Reason uh Macon was asking for to
help uh Russia the Chinese convince
Russia to come back to their senses to
come back to the to the cap of origin
and today Xi Jinping said clearly that
China was totally opposed to the use of
nuclear bacteriological and chemical
chemical weapons in a conflict so that's
a quite a breakthrough and it's uh
something which will obviously have an
impact on Russia's aggressive stance
that we've said in the past few weeks
and months
and did you want to come in at that
point
Okay so
I think
uh China has been uh clear and
consistent for 40 years that it's
following the path of peaceful
development and that a peaceful global
environment is not only in China's
interest uh but the interests of the
world so uh certainly I think this
commitment to uh resolving this conflict
uh peacefully uh can let everyone get
back uh to building a better world from
a climate perspective from uh an
economic perspective from an income
inequality perspective so uh certainly I
I think that this is uh again I think
there's very little doubt that this is
what China is aiming for
if we can come to something that Andy
was talking about a little bit earlier
Jack this idea of uh de-risking and not
decoupling
how do you read that what do you think
that actually means
de-risking in the case of Europe and
European firms is the uh is due to the
fact that they will not invest as
blindly as before and we've seen the
fact that many countries and many firms
are no longer investing massively in
China they will want to keep Chinese
factories in order to have uh the
ability to sell their goods in in China
and for example now only 10 firms are
responsible for 80 percent of investment
in China as opposed to 49 before so the
in the the five years five or six years
ago and it's due to the fact that this
awareness towards China that the court
always trust China Chinese businessman
as honest Partners they can't always
trust the Chinese legal system and
therefore now the companies we invest in
China are the ones who sell their goods
in China and the big investors are BMW
Volkswagen BASF Etc the top 10 companies
and while other companies who used to
rely on China as a cheap Workshop are
now a creative structures manufactures
factories or using factories in other
parts of the world or in Vietnam and
other other countries in Bangladesh and
moving away from China so the risking
means that yes we won't now depend on
the Chinese production machine as we saw
during the kovid it could lead to
problems in in the supply chain and they
want to avoid that at all cost in the
future
Colleen she said that China and France
have the ability and responsibility to
transcend differences and restraints as
the world undergoes undergoes profound
historical changes he's talking about
you know this concept of a new world
order that I presume China would like to
see itself at the top of it how does
that kind of talk go down in the United
States and what does it do for tensions
yeah
uh well it's certainly I mean especially
if you have an eye to the the hearings
that have been taking place on the hill
and the stand-up of the new Committee in
the house to look at
um the Chinese Communist party that
certainly feeds into The Narrative of
not just you know she's maybe looking at
a world or he's talking about a world
order with with China as a playing a
leading role or the center and that
becomes framed in in some of the U.S
political circles as China is trying to
take over the world they're going to
take over the Communist party is going
to take over all aspects of life you
know democracy as we know it is is over
this this model the Chinese model is
going to get exported everywhere
including here and so I think it you
know it has the the potential to really
be be turned and used in ways that
um make it very difficult to to focus on
anything with the China relationship
aside from competition
um if you ever recall there's the the
three pillars of the U.S
um the current Administration strategy
on China that there's the compete pillar
the Align pillar which is aligning with
allies such as Europe and in Asia and
then there's the compete in an effort to
kind of preserve the international
rules-based order as we have it now okay
and I think all the effort gets focused
on this compete and really not just
compete to preserve the order but just
compete to beat China and that that
rhetoric just really shifts the focus
there
um
I'm sorry to interrupt which is coming
to the end of the program and I wanted
to end with with Andy what's the view in
China on that does Xi Jinping see
himself as the head of the new world
order at some point
yeah
I don't think so I mean I think again
China is becoming more Central but that
doesn't mean leading the world but I
want to briefly talk about this idea of
de-risking in the business world we say
that Revenue solves a lot of problems
and one of the risks I think Europe is
facing is growth so China Imports
something like three trillion dollars a
year worth of goods which is about the
size of the French economy
and you know if Europe is able to work
with China uh France might be able to
lower the retirement age instead of
having to raise it uh because of the
trade and investment opportunities so I
think uh risk encompasses a lot of
things certainly uh some of the
questions uh Europe has or are
legitimate and should be addressed but
the risk of missing out on this
opportunity of Chinese growth uh that
could solve a lot of European domestic
problems as well okay all right we'll
have to leave it there I do appreciate
all your perspectives thank you very
much indeed to our guests there's
Jacques Orlando Colleen Cottle and Andy
mock thank you and thanks for watching
you can see the program again at any
time by visiting our website Al
jazeera.com and for further discussion
just go to our Facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash AJ Inside
Story you can of course also join the
conversation on Twitter our handle is at
AJ Inside Story for me Nick Clark and
the whole team here it's going bye for
now